in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chris
and Sandy are with us hey guys how are
ya name welcome welcome where are you
guys from
Nashua New Hampshire fun well welcome to
Nashville and who are the young men with
you this is Carter and this is Michael
and Carter is how old and Michael told
nine nine and twelve nine and twelve
years old all the way from New Hampshire
it's a bit of a travel to Nashville Wow
I hope you flew we did good very good
and here to do it that free scream
absolutely I love it how much have you
paid off go ahead two hundred and five
thousand three hundred dollars ah
excellent excellent how long did that
take you 21 months
Wow very good and your range of income
during that time between 270 and 276,000
very good what do you guys do for a
living I'm a pharmacist mm-hmm and I'm a
product manager for a biotech company
excellent very good cool so I'm gonna
guess and say some of the 205 might have
been student loans a little bit what was
it then most of it was our mortgage you
paid off your heart yes we did
absolutely you're so weird you're not
the first person that telling me that oh
that's awesome
well more people are in broken got a
mortgage man I'm telling you in debt
can't breathe everything else you guys
are like yelling your way to being rich
yeah this is very cool making a ton of
money and don't even have a mortgage
payment neat so what happened twenty-one
months ago tell me we heard you on the
radio and I introduced it to my husband
and we followed it since then that's
simple that simple didn't have to drag
me too far you were almost there already
I was almost there
well you guys were probably living
fairly conservatively anyway because
most of this was mortgaged yes yeah I
think I'd say we were pretty
conservative yeah and making a ton of
money so you're doing great you're
killing it you're rock stars and you
just leaned into it and knocked it out
house and everything in less than two
years well part of it was a Sandi said
she wanted to stay home with the boys
and I felt well if we're gonna lose half
of our income I think we should probably
have
so that's when we decided to pay off the
mortgage you have a goal that's bigger
than money then right yeah
mommy being home that's a big goal yeah
that's very cool congratulations well
very very good so you're listening on
the radio sandy comes home says Chris
we're gonna do this Chris says yes
that's so cool or did what else really
went on I listen to the podcast on my
commute to work and I and I really got
into the podcast and what you said made
a lot of sense
so I decided let's do it so you just sat
down did a budget with a yellow pad or
what happened yes in May and the first
budget being 31 days was really hard
because then we had a small break of
June being 30 days and then July in
August summer months of 31 days and 31
take forever to get through the month it
felt like mm especially first budget
talks and everything and working him out
okay all right so it was harder than it
sounded yes initially it was when you
started that first three months was
tough then yes okay
did you did you have any complete like
big fights or anything I don't think so
I mean there are little minor
disagreements but nothing that we
exploded about okay well you're kinda on
track anyway you just got to put some
legs to it exactly and so it wasn't like
this huge lurch in your value system no
it was already there you just needed
some tactical ways to apply it right so
very good very good
how does it feel you don't have a house
payment you're weird yeah it feels great
it's different man what's this house
worth uh probably like 225
I'm guessing yeah that's awesome it's
awesome and it's paid for and it's paid
for and you can do anything you wanted
now yeah how old are you - I'm gonna be
46 in May mm-hmm 47 okay and how long
have y'all been married lookey 14 years
this year okay
have you ever been debt-free while you
were married no never no I had big
student loans when we first got married
I had over a hundred thousand we got
that down to 35 when we started out the
program so okay all right so when people
hear that you've done this that you paid
off all your student
you paid off your house you paid off
everything and they asked that question
that they always asked how did you do
that what do you tell them the key to
getting out of debt is my key is
focusing on that one thing that's what
made everything because we tried so many
different ways of doing it it wasn't
until we focus on that one thing that
smallest debt focus on the little
getting it done yeah and being on the
same page is important too I can't
imagine how more much more difficult
this would have been if we were butting
heads all the time but being on the same
page kind of made it a lot easier very
cool so how involved have Michael and
Carter been actually they're pretty
involved I mean we always made sure that
they had what they needed and if they
wanted to play sports we put that in the
budget and so forth so they didn't have
to suffer too much but we did have to
say no at times I mean and they knew you
were working on this goal yes so they're
part of this debt free scream yes sir
have they been practicing that's
important a little bit a little bit
because we you know tart Carter Mike I
got to tell you we're eight kids on
their debt free scream ability here so
you're gonna get like an A or a B or C
grade on your debt free scream so you
got to bring it it's game on your mom
and dad have changed your life they've
changed your family tree so all kidding
aside this is a big deal you know you
guys are pretty incredible what you've
done for your lives and for your own
kids and for everything with is your
heroes congratulations I'm very proud of
you thank you honored to get to meet you
and thank you for making the trip all
the way from New Hampshire to the
Nashville to do this our pleasure
very fun all right here we go Kris and
Sandy Michael and Carter two hundred and
five thousand dollars paid off in 21
months making two hundred and seventy
thousand a year count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
good job guys now if you listen
carefully that was the sound of a family
tree being changed did you hear it
way to go Carter Michael good job you
get an A good job guys very well done
and they were they did great good good
screamer's very good Hey
that's important though I mean those
little guys you know 8 10 9 8 or 10
years old 12 years old they made that
trip to Nashville that time their mom
and dad paid off their house it becomes
part of the family lower part of the
legend part of the legacy and it changes
everything so that was the sound of a
family tree being changed hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that your broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you